dustin how's it going man i'm doing very
well how are you
fantastic uh so rutherford falls uh
first of all
looks hysterical for anybody who is
unfamiliar with the premise of the show
can you just quickly fill people in on
what it's all about
i'm gonna be honest it's a it's a very
simple and funny show
but it's it's actually kind of hard to
explain but
essentially uh it's about this town
called rutherford falls
and it's about sort of the uh that this
guy whose family
uh founded the town named nathan
rutherford and that's played by ed helms
and he's very much into preserving the
history of sort of the founding fathers
of his town
uh and his best friend is a woman named
regan wells played by janet schmeeding
who she works in the casino in the
cultural center for the minnesota nation
which is a reservation just
outside of rutherford falls and without
giving too much away
essentially there's kind of a a conflict
of
the two histories between nathan
rutherford's family
and the minnesota people and uh the
friendship between those two
kind of has to work some stuff out in a
very comedic and lighthearted way
uh and then it sends ripples throughout
the entire town
and uh again it's it's sort of this fun
play uh and examination of the
the history that we've all been taught
and the actual history of the indigenous
peoples united states
and uh yeah hilarity ensues
uh so you are josh in the show you're a
reporter what kind of reporter are you
and how do you fit into this world you
know josh is
kind of that uh probably little
pretentious know-it-all
woke npr reporter nothing like yourself
ah thank you appreciate not not nearly
as cool
and as uh put together as you know he's
he's kind of this guy who's
who's looking for i think a way to make
his mark
and uh he finds this story uh that's
happening in this town and decides to go
and investigate and kind of gets
involved
professionally and personally in the
goings-on of the town
and uh yeah finds himself learning a lot
more
about history and about these people
than he thought he knew and he thought
he knew a lot
there's been so much talk over the years
of representation both in in front of
the camera and in the writers room
and as those conversations have
continued this is one of those shows
that is the result of all of this hard
work and all of these conversations
where you guys have the largest
indigenous writing staff on american
television
could you feel the difference walking on
set that
this was different than where you had
been before
uh yeah like like immediately um i mean
even reading the script
and and who i was auditioning for sierra
teller and ellis who's who's the show
runner
uh she's a navajo woman uh she uh
you know i auditioned for her as well as
you know ed and mike sher and a bunch of
people and
right away you know in reading the
material you're just like oh yeah this
is
this is different this is something
special and then getting to be on set
and and just from like the costumes and
the attention to detail in
in like the production design the set
design and then as well the content of
what was being written and the stories
that were being discussed and the
nuances of language
and and of sort of inside jokes uh
there's just so much there there's it's
just such a layered and beautifully
executed
uh show in in what it represents which
is
so many different cultures all coming
together um
to like you said kind of make history in
a way and have the most representation
behind the camera and in front of it
than we've ever seen before
and uh when are you doing the movie with
diane keaton
we're shooting that right now i got to
go shoot tomorrow actually you do
what is it what is it how does she
honestly
like what uh it's insane i can't believe
we've had a few
uh moments to work together um so far
and it's honestly just such a dream like
i'm working
opposite uh such a legend and she's so
funny and exactly how you see her on
screen
is you know she's like that in real life
as well and
uh it's just i'm i'm very lucky
to be in the position that i'm in right
now where i
can be working on these two very
different but uh
in many ways uh uh life-changing
uh jobs it's it's incredible yeah so you
have diane keaton on one end and then of
course uh ed helms who you co-starred
with in
in your new show um what's is he
is he intimidating because you expect so
much from somebody like ed helms
you know like does he feel the pressure
do you think or does he walk with it
that he is always supposed to make
people laugh well i think that is a
pressure in a way you know what i mean
like because there is an
information of of you know i i'm the guy
that everyone knows you know in his case
from the office so it's like
and and and the hangover movies and so
many different things where he's that
kind of
very uh intense slightly
dorky funny guy um and i think his
character not only is a different
version of what we've expected from him
on this but
also for me to get to see his work ethic
and
how seriously he's taking it as well
because i think all of us really
you get that sense of like yeah we
really want to make this work and so
he's a total pro and also
is constantly like coming up with
different takes and different variations
of things and improvising all within
uh every single take that you get so you
really have to be on your feet and then
also again
as i keep repeating i'm also just
pinching myself every time i'm working
opposite him because it's just like
oh wow i need i need to be present in
the scene right now but he's just so
funny and uh with with the end of uh
shit's creek and the way that it all
played out especially with the award
shows
run that that thing had um
it started off this big and we all
watched the evolution of this we watched
the show become this global thing
and is your life do you feel there's a
part of it that will always be tied
to shit's creek just because how much
that little show
meant to so many people yeah you know i
think that's the thing that i'll
take away from the show like there was a
lot of great experiences on it and and
you know
there's fun to be had on set of course
and i love the cast
so much i think the audience
reception and um how much they truly
truly love and how many people
were touched by the show that's
something that
is uh it's unique you know you don't
always get that you can have a show that
critics really love or a show that is
like an underground hit
and uh in my case you have a lot of jobs
that nobody watches at all
uh but in this case this is one of those
ones that kind of
you know struck many chords with many
different people
around the world and for it as you said
to have started off so small like a
humble little
canadian show as all of our canadian
shows often start out
for it to grow the way it has and to
have the reception that it's had
it's remarkable um your your ig or
instagram
is real interesting um i quite enjoy it
i'm wondering if you have started to
fulfill
uh foot pictures for people because
apparently you have a lot of people
who are very very interested in your
feet he's on a pretty big foot
post um you get some weird posts there's
a lot of requests for people to make
videos
uh for someone's birthday or something
like that but then every now and again
yeah there's like hey post more
pics of your feet or are you ticklish
i'm not weird but
how are you doing what's the size of
your feet and it's just kind of like
okay
cool cool uh yeah i
i'm doing my best to refrain from
engaging
in uh social media in any way that
doesn't
either serve my own weird end goal of
just being weird and making weird memes
and stuff
and uh then using as a platform to put
out any kind of social or political
messages that i feel strongly about
and uh quickly before i let you go um
you
are a lot of things one of which is a
legend on
rupaul's drag race the celebrity edition
um
how did that change your life hands down
that
is one of the most important experiences
that i've ever had
in my life uh personally it was very
much a public and professional
engagement in a lot of ways but uh you
know i think
growing up like a lot of us have felt
there's there's certain roles that we're
supposed to
fit into um as as men
women or however we identify and when
those don't
quite feel right it can feel like you're
doing something wrong or there's
something wrong with you
and it can be hard to know how to
navigate through life
and when i got that opportunity i mean i
love drag race because i saw all these
people
doing this thing like just living their
true authentic selves in such a
brilliant creative hilarious
and and impactful way and when i got a
chance to do that
not only did it free me up from any kind
of uh sort of masculinity
gender hinderances that i experienced in
my life but also
it allowed me my our challenge on it was
to do essentially like a stand-up thing
to do a roast
which is something that i've always
wanted to be i've always dreamt of being
like a stand-up comedian
and to actually have all of those
experiences kind of crammed
into one uh and to look
in my opinion to look as gorgeous as i
did
i'm gonna say it uh it was incredible
and and honestly
any opportunity anybody who gets a
chance to
be professionally made up and put into
drag by uh
by queens and and professional air
people please do it because honestly it
will
change your life as it certainly did
mine
you